et que l'une de ses habitants de
l'immeuble on a d'ailleurs vu dans le
reportage hélène roger bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous d'avoir accepté
de témoigner en direct sur arte france
vous fait donc partie de ces familles
qui font la grève des loyers est ce que
ça a été une décision évidente pour vous
spontanée vous avez dû réfléchir
pourquoi en tout cas vous avez accepté
cette méthode
voilà très déterminé en tout cas en fait
c'est fait effectivement assez
rapidement on s'est retrouvé en fait au
mois d'avril avec des charges qui nous
ont été demandées qui étaient très
importantes à se retrouver confinait je
pense que beaucoup de gens l'ont vécu on
s'est aussi retrouvée nous dans la cour
de l'immeuble a échangé un peu plus que
d'habitude et du coup on a pu aussi
partager un peu nos difficultés nos
questionnements par rapport à la
situation et du coup suite à ce rappel
de charge très très important qui
arrivait à un moment très opportun on va
dire on a commencé à réfléchir d'une des
locataires a contacté l'association
droit au logement et voilà les temps
avec lui et en réfléchissant avec nous
on s'est dit qu'on voulait participer à
toute leur campagne de moratoire sur les
loyers et demander justement qui est
cette cette opération me rattrape sur
les loyers qu'ils soient mises en france
comment ont réagi les propriétaires
parce qu'on rappelle que c'est un parc
privé ce ne sont pas voilà ce n'est pas
publique
ce sont donc des propriétaires
d'immeubles qui ne perçoivent pas de
loyer on imagine que c'est alors
certains peut-être ne peuvent pas
s'apitoyer sur des propriétaires non ça
peut être difficile aussi pour eux
d'être privé de ses loyers ils étaient
peut-être aussi dans des situations
compliquées avec cette crise du coc vide
oui peut-être je vous avoue que ça je
sais pas ce que je sais c'est que on a
un seul bailleur surtout l'immeuble on
n'a pas plusieurs bailleurs plusieurs
propriétaires individuels
donc c'est un gros bailleurs qui gère
l'entièreté de l'immeuble après ce qui
s'est passé c'est que nous on a créé ce
comité des locataires pour justement un
peu suivre les revendications et pouvoir
se mettre ensemble pour suivre toute la
mobilisation et on a envoyé un courrier
à la société de gestion qui avec
laquelle on est en lien pour faire un
petit peu l'état des lieux et demander
justement un rendez-vous pour point
évoqué les situations à la fois les
situations de difficultés par rapport au
paiement des loyers mais aussi des
difficultés
l'entretien des appartements etc et donc
on a reçu une réponse à peu près une
semaine ou dix jours plus tard voilà
c'était un peu un évitement et on a
répondu effectivement comme je le disais
qu'on ne pouvait pas venir nous voir à
cause du fonctionnement on espère qu'on
va avoir le rendez vous très bien
aujourd'hui dans quelle situation
etes-vous aucun revenu pendant le
confinement
alors vous - personnellement moi je les
ai effectivement les locataires qui ont
décidé de ne plus payer effectivement
leurs charges on imagine que même été
dans des situations difficiles
alors en fait nous on a décidé de faire
une opération commune et solidaire ya
parmi nous des gens qui ne peuvent
absolument pas payer leur loyer qui
n'ont pas eu leurs revenus depuis le moi
de le début du mois de mars
et puis il ya des gens qui pourraient
éventuellement payer leur loyer mais qui
par solidarité avec les autres ont
décidé de ne pas payer leur loyer pour
l'instant aujourd'hui c'est une grève
des loyers dans le privé
c'est une démarche plutôt inédite et on
l'a vu dans leur partage soutenu par par
le dal l'organisation tout à fait en
fait droit au logement nous a vraiment
accompagner nous a conseillés et c'est
vraiment avec eux qu'on avance dans
cette aventure je dirais d'ailleurs
j'invite tout le monde à aller signer
leur pétition pour un moratoire sur les
loyers qui est sûr le lycée le site
loyer suspendu point org pour participer
aussi à cette campagne
aujourd'hui clairement ce que vous vous
craignez d'être obligé de rembourser
tous les loyers rétroactivement que dit
la loi sur sur ce plan alors je suis pas
une spécialiste
l'enseigné on imagine tout l'immeuble
avant de prendre cette décision
oui tout à fait pour l'instant on est
vraiment dans une phase pendant deux
mois en fait on a vraiment une phase qui
est une phase de négociations pendant
laquelle il peut pas y avoir d'action en
justice trop importante
ce qu'ils peuvent mettre le loyer de
côté bien évidemment pour pouvoir le
régler
si jamais on a un rappel à la loi de
payer et puis voilà on est dans cette
période des deux mois qui nous permet
d'essayer d'instaurer un dialogue avec
notre bailleur et de poing avancer sur
cette question
merci hélène roger habitante de
l'immeuble en grève
voyez de bagnolet d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous